regardez bien
3 2 1
là haut c'est mademoiselle tarentule
notre hacker personnel notre moteur de
recherche de poche notre prodige de
l'informatique nous l'appelons la toile
bien joué la toile je sais pris le
contrôle de centrale de police brouiller
leurs systèmes d'imagerie parce qu'elle
est bloqué au sol leurs hélicos et pour
finir je me dis pas que j'aime livraison
spéciale pour
joyeux anniversaire
je crois bien que je te déteste en
apparence
vous êtes tous les cinq devoyault des
prédateurs
des sociopathes sans pitié au jeu vous
en prie vous me faites rouler si
on est les bad guys professeur d'accord
je t'en supplie soit subtil jeu de
hawache à sahl et bada hateley si vous
voulez éviter la prison vous devez
devenir gentil tu nous fais quoi là nous
allons faire semblant de devenir gentil
pour pouvoir rester rentables
pouvez vous aider cette grand-mère pour
traverser la rue du gros test en riant
ferrals
on est plus que des méchants qui font
peur ils nous aiment vous êtes ainsi
gentil petit car j'ai plus envie de quoi
un bas de gamme non nous serons toujours
des bagages je veux que vous partagiez
le nom loser ça valait le coup quand
même
[Musique]